to be very small very hot very dense
that is its birth state
it was burst into that state so it's not
how did it become that right that's how
it was born and it has to do with this
pocket of energy that slides into a a
configuration
that has such extreme temperatures and
densities where when you are that hot
and that dense you only have one thing
you can do and that's rapidly expand if
you have a hill that goes into like a
little Basin and it rains and all water
collects in that Basin but wait a minute
that's not the lowest place that water
can be right because there's an even
lower point on the other side of this
little bump it is possible for the water
on this side of the bump to Tunnel
through to the other side of the bump if
it does that then it falls to the bottom
catastrophically and that falling to the
bottom is the birth of Another Universe